[Music]
have you ever wanted to release a CD of
music oh honey please now saying that I
wish I could
and then accepting that you can't
teaches you that you suck I only want to
do things that I think I could do a good
job at rise and shine it's an spresso
time what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message know your
strengths over to you Oprah Winfrey also
if you want to know what Oprah Winfrey
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you or real
work is to figure out where your power
bases
[Music]
you've done magazines you've done movies
you've done television have you ever
wanted to release a CD of music oh honey
please no no I you know what I think one
of the things I learned growing up
watching other people like Johnny Carson
for example was was a mentor in a way
because he always understood what he
could and could not do and I truly
understand that that is not something I
could do I mean I attempted it just as a
fun thing a couple years ago run on run
on I got stuck a hare myself that's why
we that's why we cut it off I wished I
could it's the one thing I wish I could
do but I think it's a gift to be able to
sing and that's not what I was given but
since I was given so many other if you
haven't I wish I could list you will
never be happy you need to learn to
eliminate your negative self-talk if you
ever catch yourself saying I wish I
could then you need to feel the poison
in those words and immediately take
action if you don't if you allow your
brain to tell you all of the things that
you're not capable of doing you will
never be happy you'll constantly talk
yourself down from doing the things that
will ultimately give you the greatest
joy happiness satisfaction in your life
because you are allowing your brain to
take control of the things that your
heart should really be deciding now it's
easy to look at Oprah and say she's got
it all figured out she's massively
wealthy she's had tons of success and
she's insanely happy and she teaches
other people how to be happy she has it
all figured out newsflash
Oprah is also a human in an amazing
human and that love Oprah Winfrey and
she's one of my favorites of all time
but she's still human and she still has
limiting beliefs and this is one of them
that we just exposed if she really
wanted to be a singer and release an
album there's a lot of ways that she
could do it she could go to class she
could get a coach he could get training
she could practice she could get better
and better and better and improve her
skill she could do spoken word she could
do rap she could focus on the message
instead of the voice she could do
auto-tune there's a lot of different
ways that you could actually get a
message out there
nobody praises Bob Dylan Willie Nelson
Eminem for their amazing voices
wasn't the voice that mattered it was
the epic message that came along with
all of their songs that ended up
changing the world now maybe I'm wrong
maybe Oprah doesn't actually care that
much about being a singer but my issue
is with the word choice saying that I
wish I could and then accepting that you
can't teaches you that you suck the more
that you say I wish I could and then
accepting that you can't go off and do
that thing instead of finding a way to
do it even in a different way than most
people think
but being resourceful and finding a way
is the path to self-esteem is the path
to happiness and the more that you teach
and the more that you say and the more
that you are around people who say I
wish I could if that's in your
environment if that's in your head
you're teaching yourself that you suck
and that's toxic to me okay so what do
you do how do you get rid of the
negative self-talk I'm gonna give you
three suggestions that I think will help
you step number one is identify what the
negative self-talk
is that you have what is the thing that
you keep telling yourself over and over
and over again in the back your head
when you look at yourself in the mirror
when you try to take on a new challenge
what is the thing are you saying I wish
I could or something else
write it down give it a name what is
your negative self-talk number two is
have someone hold you accountable so the
next time anybody around you hears you
saying this they need to tell you they
need to say hey you said it again they
need to scratch you or tap you on the
shoulder or whatever the thing is so for
me it was complaining I wanted to stop
complaining even though I don't complain
that much but I asked everybody around
me tell me when I am complaining I need
you to call me out on it and the default
reactions but you don't complain I'm not
perfect I complained you have to call me
out on it and my son in particular loves
calling me out when I'm complaining
having people to hold you accountable
when you don't catch it when you fall
back into default negative self-talk
mode is super super super important and
step number three is do a daily check-in
find something in your routine that
happens frequently enough that you can
tie it to this to a daily check-in to
say how am i doing am I on track am i
complaining am i hearing that negative
cell top again and so for example any
time you're driving and you hit a red
light it's a good time to do check-in
anytime you are stuck waiting for an
elevator
it's
good time to do a check-in am i hitting
negative self-talk how is my day going
so far am i proud of myself am i happy
with the direction I'm going today or
have I caught a few of these moments and
I need to fix them so identify what your
negative self-talk is find somebody to
hold you accountable and do daily
check-ins now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is the single most important piece of
negative self-talk that is in your
language that you want to eliminate
voice it put in the comments below I'm
curious to see what you have to say
do you ever like get offered parts like
where you play something totally
different like a like you know I mean
like you're a kid you're concerned
father and you're into divorce and like
it's a real soft roll and you just don't
want to do a daughter got kidnapped and
now he must save her no but I mean
something that's so out of the Mafia
mathematician is going through a bitter
divorce oh yeah no I don't get off you
want to do one or no no really you know
I mean I only want to do things that I
think I could do a good job at and I
think I'll be no good at that really
just you know I'm not an actor really I
mean I used to you know work jewelry and
pinch jewelry on this remodeling a -
you're right
you know as a sportsman for years I'm
not really somethi spean that can adopt
and chameleon in himself into different
roles I just got into this by you know
being at the right place at the right
time I was you know working working in
the street selling jewelry and I got
plucked from obscurity into the movie
industry so it's not like I spent years
honing out do different accents or
pretending here you know I accept what
I'm good at
or if well I'll be good at any of it but
I accept what I feel that I'm confident
and just try and go with the flow in
that direction you know there's an
entrepreneur you typically want to do it
all and a lot of times in the very
beginning you are wearing every at and
trying to do it all and you have to be
resourceful you have to be willing to
get your hands dirty and do a little bit
of everything in the beginning but then
it's like okay really buckle down and I
even had to go through this with myself
you know there was times I was like
trying to do too much I do trying to do
it all and like figure out like what am
I really really passionate about what am
I really great at what does that one
thing that I can do the very best on my
team to add the most value you know for
the you know for this idea of business
and then so figuring out okay who do you
really need you know do you need that
chief operating officer that person
that's gonna really help you with the
operations and logistics and the
infrastructure who do you need that you
know Marc is someone that's gonna handle
your marketing that's just badass and
all they care about is like how they're
gonna be able to tell this story to the
marketplace and be able to retain
people that become customers and you
know who are the people that you need
you know around you and what are you
really truly great at the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be kind
of like a little beacon if you want to
hear Oprah's best life-changing advice
check out the link right next to me I
think you'll enjoy the video continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I love the theory of that there's 10,000
hours behind anybody who ever gets to be
successful